what what's the biggest kind of like
turnaround story that that that pops
into your head with a specific with a
specific dog they're so in prison
specifically doesn't matter I think the
some of the most beautiful
Rehabilitation that I've witnessed
between man and dog man and mut if you
will has been in the positive change
program because we've sent in some
really broken dogs who did not trust
people one one of them Smokey so I get a
call from the Animal control officer the
lead at the Mojave animal shelter and
she says I got a dog for you I really
don't want to have to put him down I've
been pushing it off for 3 weeks and
she's the one that's got to stick the
needle in so yeah you know she's kind of
begging me to come out there and meet
him she sends me a picture it's an
adorable looking Cattle Dog right but
he's got a scowl and a look in his eyes
where I know this dude is off I know he
is he is something is wrong with
something I don't want to say wrong but
he he's uh he's had some experiences in
life that have set him back straight up
so I get out there to the kennel card
and get out there to his kennel and his
kennel card says hates people that's
just so the notes are just it says he
hates people right I go all right what
are we what are we going to do with this
here yeah so I put a you know Caesar
always teaches us no touch no talk no
eye contact so rather because all of
those things are pressure and this is a
dog that doesn't need any pressure right
now so simply put a leash on him turned
and walked out let him hop in the car
himself and I thought to myself this you
know this dog is going to need if he has
any hope at all to be adopted because
he'd already bitten several people
that's why he was there um he he needs
to go into positive change and he needs
to find someone who has a SI sense about
emotional connection and a six sense
of almost superhuman ability to um
convey positive energy and I knew just
who that person was and his name is
Jason Mory he is out of prison now he's
probably the best dog trainer in Orange
County huh and Jason Mory turned that
dog around like you would not believe we
we couldn't really have many people
involved usually we have three students
we pair outside of their race you know
California state prisons are extra
extraordinarily segregated racially so
we always have people of various racial
backgrounds paired up on one dog it's
three students per dog and is that
that's pretty singular for programs I
mean is is that who whose idea was that
and and and and why do that well we we
knew we kind of had to especially
because we were we were teaching on on
Maximum Security Prison yards where it
was very it was um the racial politics
were were very real yeah and so the best
way we could figure out how to how to
get everyone to get along and and kind
of team up over this this greater good
and it was to you know pair them up
together that's great and it really
worked out well sure it's really really
been something special maybe we can
expand on that later but Jason you know
and
Jason Jason Mory is a special human
being he is a guy that did a long time
in prison and um once he found his
natural
ability to transmit positive energy into
another human in into another being I
think his life changed forever and he
knew exactly what he wanted to do cuz he
turned that dog around like you would
not believe and he knew exactly how to
do it and um he would just start out by
saying you know my responsibility here
is to is to let him know that I've got
him that no matter what this dog knows
that every step he takes I have his back
I've got you I've got you I've got you
and he is breathing that into himself
and he's sending it down that leash and
he's doing it with his touch and he's
doing it with how he how he stands
there's something very impressive about
the prison population and how they how
their body language is dogs pick up on
body language and Jason has this
beautiful presence to himself he has
this you know this this wonderful stance
and he just conveys um confidence and
self-esteem and I got you so this dog
was scared of everything the reason he
bit so many things is not because he's
aggressive it's because he was scared he
was intimidated he didn't understand
what was going on around him so Jason
started out for weeks with just I got
you just building him up with I got you
and then from that point on when that
dog started to realize that things were
that things weren't as scary as he
thought they were as most of as happens
with most of us um he started to really
become a dog and he started to wag his
tail and he started to to be
extraordinarily affectionate and he
started to deal with other students and
he he just truly rehabilitated he
changed that dog's entire life and um I
I I contend to this day that that only
could have happened in prison yeah you
know because the the boundaries the
rules the exercise the discipline the
structure that we have in there is
exactly what a dog need like that needs
you know um and yeah so his family
actually adopted Smokey so when he got
out of prison Smokey was waiting for him
oh that's so cool man Smokey's passed
away since but uh Jason's been training
now for I think four years he's been a
professional dog trainer and he's doing
an incredible job uh he's he along with
25 other of our former students are
professional dog trainers these are
almost all long-term incarcerated a lot
of black and brown gang members people
that you would never expect to be
involved in in the the pet industry are
not only involved in the pet industry
but are doing incredible incredible work
most of them working within the rescue
system does the program take part in
sort of in in their parole and in in in
their sort of PL and how how does that
work ABS yeah
so to for the most part um our students
can reenroll in the program as many
times as they want because that's
something that we need because you're
you're you are adding on to your skill
set every round that you do you know so
that's something that's very important
to us to have a base so that we can re
rehabilitate difficult dogs but at some
of our institutions we're able to
provide Milestones Milestones are
considered by parole and probation you
know for release we write letters to uh
the parole board for our students you
know talking about their the content of
their character how they've applied
themselves in the program um we don't
have I don't believe we have rat credits
but there's a variety of different we
are approved at an Institutional level
to help people get out of prison earlier
because they are what what the parole
board wants to see and what the prison
system wants to see is that you are
taking your time seriously and that you
are working to rehabilitate yourself
there are very few programs in prison
it's very hard to do um but you know
positive change is an incredible
commitment it's it's 14 weeks we're only
in there once a week so we go in once a
week for about four hours to train with
our students and the rest of the time
it's the mentor trainers and the lead
trainers that are leading class to to
make things possible but they're
training 14 hours a day seven days a
week for 14 weeks so those dogs are all
day long all day long in the Pod on the
yard we usually have kind of an Al Cove
that's connected we usually go through
the showers to get to a back area where
where we have like our kennels but for
the most part the dogs are with a
student all day long the only time
they're not is when they're sleeping or
they're at cowo you know wow yeah wow so
they're working all day long and not
only have we help helped a lot I'll tell
you a wonderful story so I was on um we
were pushing for Criminal Justice Reform
in Washington um Congressman Kevin
McCarthy is my congressman he's always
been extraordinarily support supportive
of the program um which was unique from
from the right because what i' always
been taught is the right that's not
somewhere you go so when Kevin from day
one I I've known him since 2011 he's
been supportive you know really trying
to help a dog guy he is yeah yeah and uh
he invited us out to Washington and I
didn't know what to expect this is this
is me and students so these are formerly
incarcerated students and and Daniel had
just gotten out of prison and so I'm
there with Daniel who was incarcerated
at 17 Mr Robinson if you're out there I
love you and uh he gave us the capital
Dome tour wow which only a handful of
people get this tour and so we're
standing on top of the capital Dome
after getting this beautiful tour
walking up these old staircase there's
the graffiti in there from like the late
1800s there's all this crazy stuff and
we get up to the top
and Daniel's like hey man you know just
kind of realizing uh if I had to serve
my Max term you know I would still be in
prison but instead you know I was in the
positive change program and uh I'm
standing on top of the capital building
it's pretty crazy you know so had it not
been for positive change he would still
be in prison and instead he's standing
on top of the capital with me looking
out over the mall
[Music]
wow